So, how do you go about
choosing a library?
There's a few things to look at.
Central to everything is functionality.
So, the first step is to figure out
what the library actually gives you.
If the source code is available, that
would be the ultimate source of truth,
but it's probably not
the best place to start.
Instead, consider looking for an
overview Readme or a Quick Start Guide.
These should help you get
the essence of the library and
highlight the common use cases.
The library really makes easy,
ideally, these should match
exactly what you need to do.
This is also where Integration and
Instructions should be found.
Finding easy to understand
gradal instructions,
can make a huge difference
in getting up and running.
Lack of gradal instructions might
mean extra pain and maintenance time.
For UI libraries,
you might also look for screen shots,
videos, a demo app or
real world apps that use the library.
All can be powerful signals
in determining if this is
actually what you need.
There are specific things you
need that aren't readily visible,
may be time to look
through the documentation.
Good documentation is a sign that
the library developers care a lot
about the developer
usability of their library.
Two other factors you might
consider are recent activity and
whether there is a community
around the library.
Both are good signs that if
you come across an issue, or
a bug, you won't be on your own.
While none of these things except the
core functionality are deal breakers,
there is a strong correlation
between these factors and
well designed and useful libraries.